depuis qu'internet révolutionne les
relations entre les hommes en faisant
tomber les barrières des frontières nos
vies nos sentiments notre quotidien
risque de devenir de moins en moins
concret est de plus en plus virtuel
exemple les tamagotchi une invention
japonaise que l'on peut traduire par
adorable petit des poussins virtuel
qu'on soigne qu'on élève qu'on nourrit
un jouet qui fait fureur au japon et qui
débarque en france
notre enquête de ce soir mené par
stéphane haumant marié d'une bruno et
christian hottin est intitulé
virtuellement votre inattendu mais ma
salut à tous je m'appelle bête et qiu bo
et je suis chanteuse
voix de lolita et mensurations idéales
la première artiste virtuel doit tout à
l'ordinateur date ekoko a vendu peu de
disques mais son clip a fait le tour du
monde tout simplement cyber star elle a
aussi ses avantages
la chanteuse ne mange pas permet pas de
scandale et surtout elle n'est jamais
malade les oiseaux les univers virtuels
passionne les japonais dès le plus jeune
âge quand il se vend 100 mille consoles
de jeux en france
il s'en vend 1 million au japon 10 fois
plus akihabara un quartier de tokyo
surnommée la ville de l'électronique
dans un pays comme le japon éclaté en
3300 il
internet s'est imposé en quelques mois
comme un formidable outil de
communication mais dans les cybercafés
la recherche d'emploi sur le net ou le
shopping virtuel sont dépassés un très
sérieux - debout disque propose un
cimetière virtuel c'est la dernière
nouveauté vous choisissez la forme de
votre tombe et vous y inscrive et le nom
de l'être cher
vous pouvez ainsi vous recueillir devant
votre ordinateur
plus convivial mais tout aussi virtuel
le tamagotchi un petit oeuf
électroniques dont il faut s'occuper
comme d'un animal domestique en
pianotant sur ce but on n'a pas de
salaire
il a un petit peu faim ekwalla lagon qui
gagnent des wagons qui est très bon
parce qu'il est bien de jouer car il
connaît l'éducation est très encadrée
quand il est jeune il faut le le vers 9
heures de coucher à 8
si on les ducaux mal elle ne respecte
plus les horaires il ne mange plus
devient sale et les grands aujourd'hui
dans les rues de tokyo le poussin
virtuel se négocie au marché noir
les magasins sont en rupture de stock
alors les vendeurs à la sauvette en
profite
les prix flambent 2500 francs pièce 25
fois le prix officiel 7 millions
d'exemplaires vendus en quelques mois un
succès foudroyant
un japonais sur six se déclarent prêts à
adopter un tamagotchi les tamagotchi
c'est mieux qu'un chien on donne de
l'affection lésiné moins exigeants
le fabricant se tournent désormais vers
l'exportation 20 millions de poussins
virtuels devraient être vendus cette
année aux états unis en europe et la
voilà en france on en a déjà vendu 25
milles en 3 semaines dans ce magasin
maintenant il faut s'inscrire sur liste
d'attenté
alors les tamagotchi sont actuellement
en stock vous avez la possibilité de
réserver
mais qu'est ce qui pousse les enfants et
par la même occasion les parents à
acheter ce petit oeuf à 99 francs
c'est mieux d'avoir un animal au moins
ça leur apprend à être un petit peu
responsable si c'est comme un petit
enfant on doit l'élever lui donne à
manger
bref un personnage électronique avec des
envies et des besoins plus qu'un simple
objet les professionnels ne s'y sont pas
trompés c'est un produit qui est
affectif c'est un produit qui est
personnel c'est un produit avec lequel
on peut on peut presque dialoguer donc
ça c'est tous les ingrédients du succès
pour un joueur alors selon lui dans la
moyenne
il fait fureur dans les cours de récré
les enfants font des concours de
longévité
si on le néglige il peut mourir une tête
de mort à côté il ya les figures parfois
de pas trop cela prépa c'est beaucoup le
tamagotchi et comme tous les phénomènes
de mode
il ne durera qu'un temps mais le
transfert des motions vers une machine
suscite déjà bien des questions ça me
paraît dangereux sidi un crew comme tout
et machines pas du tout si la de sylla
une affectivité kiki et qui est normal
autour de lui je crois qu'on peut s'en
amuser mais en revanche ça doit pas
remplacer quelque chose il reste encore
des enfants qui préfèrent le réel mais
déjà un fabricant prépare un nouveau
produit un bébé virtuel qu'il faudra
élever jusqu à l'âge adulte
contradictions et en couleurs on
n'arrête pas le progrès